hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump and tech companies
clashing yet again
facebook and twitter removing a video
from the president and his campaign's
accounts
claiming it spreads coronavirus
misinformation
the move re-sparking censorship
accusations against
these platforms media buzz host howard
kurtz
shares his insights on the social media
company's policing content
and details whether he thinks they are
specifically targeting the
commander-in-chief
and with polls suggesting 2020 may be an
uphill battle for the president fox news
senior political analyst brit hume says
mr trump
should be looking to late republican
congressman jack kemp
and some of his bold ideas to win
re-election
brit hume joins the rundown to discuss
the 2020 race
our country's response to the pandemic
and the new fox nation documentary
the jack kemp playbook which he narrates
plus commentary by fox news legal
analyst greg
jarrett the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
and this is the fox news rundown
friday august 7 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
more and more content from the president
and his campaign is being taken down
from social media
as the major companies insist the
content is false
but are they walking a fine line i think
right now facebook
twitter and google they've got two
choices
either they step up their game on
policing their own content
or the government is going to get ticked
off and do it for them
i'm lisa brady polls suggest 2020
may be an uphill battle for president
trump could revisiting a former
quarterback's playbook
be his key to re-election well taking a
page out of jack kemp's playbook in
terms of his added outward attitudes
toward people would would certainly help
although it may be too late
for that for donald trump because people
have figured out what to think of it
and i'm greg jarrett i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
on thursday president trump went to ohio
and during his visit
he said this about his democratic
opponent in the presidential race joe
biden he's against god he's against guns
he also said the other side is against
religion and the bible
now some will probably disagree with
those statements possibly
very strongly and argue they are false
but
what happens if video of the president
saying those things
ends up on twitter or facebook courtesy
of the trump campaign or
a pac will the social media companies
take it down
because that's what facebook and twitter
just did with a clip of president trump
saying this on fox and friends
children are almost and i would almost
say
definitely but almost immune from this
disease
twitter blocked the trump campaign from
tweeting again until it removed the
video
and facebook just removed the content
saying it was false information about
the virus
it's been quite a journey on this front
for facebook ceo mark zuckerberg had
resisted flagging political content
he told fox's dana purino in late may we
have a different policy
i think than twitter on this you know i
i just believe strongly that
that facebook shouldn't be the arbiter
of truth of everything that people say
online
they have continued to support political
ads even after twitter had said they
would ban ads
but after several vocal employees
blasted facebook for allowing certain
posts namely from the president
and some businesses boycotted the
company began to remove and flag more
content
facebook shifted its stance well i know
what the president and his allies say
which is that facebook twitter all of
silicon valley are biased against him
and the republican party and
conservatives and they are
in the process of seizing upon that to
say this is one more example of bias
holly kurtz is the host of media buzz on
fox news
but the way that the social media giants
look at it
is that they have taken a very firm line
against anyone but of course the
president attacks him
attracts the most attention who spreads
what they deem to be covet 19
misinformation and look the president i
think could have chosen his words more
carefully he said
kids are almost immune the cdc figures
show that
7.4 percent of cases are children under
18 so they're obviously not
completely immune but there was some
misreporting on this the washington post
had to run a correction after saying
that the president had been taken down
on facebook and twitter that the
president
had been barred temporarily from
tweeting it was actually the trump
campaign yeah
um howie what is going to happen with
with social media
because it sounds like there's a lot of
there is a lot of talk
in congress and it's not just on the
republican side right about
the liability protection uh that is
afforded to social media under what we
know as section 230
if you aren't acting solely as a
bulletin board right for everything
and you are flagging content or taking
it down
even whether or not you love or hate the
president does that put you in
in a different category you know these
social media companies don't have a lot
of friends these days you think a few
short years ago when mark zuckerberg was
like a folk hero
movies were being made about him jack
dorsey of twitter the same thing
because for people on the right who as i
mentioned earlier have this distrust of
the zuckerbergs of the world um any time
that they act to take down content that
emanates from the gop or conservative
side
that cried's foul but the democrats
aren't big fans of tech either these
days in fact elizabeth warren when she
was a presidential candidate
wanted to break up facebook because they
feel that
facebook isn't and and it's it's
brethren
aren't doing enough uh to regulate uh
the content on their sites here's the
deal
uh they've gotten away for years they've
made zillions and zillions of dollars
free content that all of us provide and
they say oh we're not media companies
we're just a bulletin board
we're like the electric company anybody
can put it wherever they want well
that's no longer going to cut it because
people do post
hate speech bullying threats
disinformation and sometimes as we saw
in the 2016 campaign outright
foreign propaganda so facebook and
twitter are now
trying to step up and be a little more
vigilant about taking down stuff that is
just plain wrong particularly when it
comes to
the pandemic but it costs a lot of money
they haven't wanted to spend a lot of
money
and i think this middle ground that they
have where they only do a few things
selectively
is not going to fly and they are risking
a backlash that could end up with some
government regulation
yeah what do you think is going to win
out this whole anti-trust argument that
the democrats are pushing or
this section 230 you lose your liability
because you're essentially a publisher
argument that
more conservatives are pushing i think
they have more uh
to fear from the conservative side uh
because there is a special exemption for
social media companies that a regular
media company would not have when when
something is
broadcast on television when something
is published in the newspaper or online
you can be sued for libel you can be
sued for defamation
uh they have this sort of exemption that
says well it's somebody else's content
and you know we didn't really look at it
very carefully i just don't think that's
gonna fly
the antitrust thing seems to me to be
punitive you know these are fabulously
successful companies because they
created products that people want to use
and they give them away for free except
they get all your data and you get a lot
of targeted advertising that you don't
like
uh so i think it's a stretch to say they
can be broken up under anti-trust laws
i'm not sure what they did that was
illegal
i do think they have been mismanaging uh
both privacy issues and this whole issue
of of
content policing in a way that is now
coming back to bite them
i want to ask you it seemed like
facebook for a while was trying
not to really get that involved right
that you know mark zuckerberg
famously said you know we don't want to
be the arbiters of truth meanwhile
twitter was basically going to town
right
basically this year twitter started to
to really
um shift its tactics with with the
president's
content mostly the president's content
it seemed what
what happened why did twitter seemingly
shift this year was it the virus an
election year
what happened i don't think you can
divorce what's happening right now from
the fact that it is an election year i
am sure many of people who work for
twitter
uh would love to see president trump out
of office that's not to say that i think
that
you know everything they do is is biased
or ended only one
uh side of the political equation now if
they were to
be equally aggressive against prominent
democrats joe biden just isn't as much
of a
controversial force on social media so
he doesn't get as much of this but even
other prominent democrats then i think
they could make the case that they are
being even-handed but it seems like the
combination
of the coronavirus the
uh racial violence and protests and the
fact that we have an election going on
has uh sort of made everybody intensify
their efforts
and facebook what what do you think
happened there why
why are they sort of i don't know if the
word caving is
is appropriate but they certainly seem
to do it about face from we're not the
arbiters
arbiters of truth and we're not going to
dictate what content has allowed
to now they are sort of more involved in
this in much the same way twitter is
what do you think happened there was
that because of the the boycott that
they shifted their stance
you know about a hundred major companies
did boycott and i think it gave facebook
a big black eye but facebook is such a
global force that it probably didn't
in my view cause a huge financial hit i
think
zuckerberg just got embarrassed i think
mark zuckerberg uh
his position wasn't untenable well we'll
let the marketplace decide
anybody can post whatever they want and
i'm not going to get involved in being
the arbor and so forth
except when you are and so if you make
exceptions for
the pandemic and then you make an
exception for the campaign then you make
an exception for misinformation about
this or that
then you are in the content policing
business and you can't be a little bit
pregnant on this and i think
zuckerberg with some of these
well-publicized controversies
uh in the end had no choice now he's
still uh
sort of dipping his toe in these waters
i think
look i think right now facebook twitter
and google
they've got two choices either they step
up their game on policing their own
content
or the government is going to get ticked
off and do it for them i prefer they did
it themselves
okay howie briefly before i let you go
let's talk about debates or the talk
about
the talk about debates are are they they
going to happen or
is this just some people in the media is
this more of a media issue
related issue to talk about whether or
not we should even have them
well there's two strands here one is a
number of media liberals
um including elizabeth drew
and thomas freeman both writing in the
new york times
have suddenly decided that presidential
debates are so
silly and pointless and superficial
let's just get rid of them which is
another way of saying
joe biden shouldn't have to debate
president trump and i think there are
some who feel like biden's ahead in the
campaign
they'd love for him not to have to risk
it all with a poor
debate performance or two and to me
that's hypocrisy because if donald trump
had blown off the debates in 2016
many of these people their heads would
have exploded so i don't think that's
going to go anywhere biden says he will
participate
on the other side you've got president
trump who wants uh to add a fourth
debate or at least an earlier debate
uh moving up to early september in part
because of the surge of male and voting
which he also opposes
it is true a lot of people will have
voted by the time we get around to what
is now scheduled to be
the first debate in late september uh i
think
uh the commission on presidential debate
which is independent which picks the
moderators which decides the dates
it's much better for everybody and
healthy for the whole system
if they get to make these decisions no
they could decide to move up the debate
i
doubt that will happen i do strongly
believe that this fall just as
every four years since 1976 we will see
uh debates between these two candidates
i want to ask you briefly about optics
as well right we're not having normal
conventions
wondering if that takes something away
from
the political process i imagine of
course it does right on its face of
course
but is it somewhat irrelevant right now
because everybody's sort of on the same
page about
this virus so if if no one is holding
the grand
convention and the grand acceptance
speech then
it's just an even playing field and we
move on from this yeah but there's no
question that
you know it's unfortunate and yet it's
necessary
uh to not have you know 30 000 people
descending on milwaukee or charlotte or
was going to be jacksonville before the
president
pulled the plug but it does make for
sort of an antiseptic campaign i i think
joe biden
uh has done very few interviews and very
little in-person campaigning i
understand why i'm not sure he can
sustain that september and october
i'm not saying big rallies nobody's
going to be doing that in this
environment
and i think the president has an
advantage there because he's got the
giant bully pulpit he can have the
coronavirus briefings every day
in the white house he is getting you
know i mean at least 10 if not 100 times
more coverage than biden
the twist here is that biden people like
it that way because they think the
president is often hurting himself and
they're
adopting this low key strategy all of
which means these three debates
even if they're just in in studios with
no audience
are going to be probably even more
crucial than usual
uh for that small minority of americans
who haven't already made up their minds
about this presidential race and all the
more reason
why i hope they come off as planned
howie finally um
the biden folks might might like that
they think the president hurts himself
is biden hurting himself as well at
times
when he goes out there uh you know some
of the comments
that have been made about especially
we're in this time of of racial tension
the former vice president recently said
the latino community's
different from the african-american
community because it has diversity of
thought
um and the whole if you don't you know
if you don't vote for me you ain't black
are those kinds of things
getting in in biden's way or is he
treated
just so differently by the media and by
his base
that it doesn't matter no i think when
biden makes a significant gaffe
it gets a lot of media coverage but
because he is doing so few interviews
and because he's doing
taking so few questions from his own
press corps he just isn't providing
as many opportunities as would be the
case maybe in the normal non-pandemic
campaign so it seems to me if you look
at the scoreboard i mean look
whatever people think about president
trump he talks to reporters virtually
every day
he sat down for an hour with chris
wallace he sat down for a half an
hour with jonathan swan of axios he made
make mistakes in these interviews but
he's out there
and he's doing what i think every
candidate has to do hitting major league
pitching
the press needs to be much more
concerned about biden's lack of access
and there i think a little bit of bias
is showing there should be a drum beat
every day that joe biden
he's the nominee of one of the two major
parties should get out there and answer
questions and by the way
if biden doesn't do more of that he may
be a little rusty
uh when it comes time for the actual
debates howie kurtz thank you so much
for your time
good to talk to you
[Music]
this is greg jarrett with your fox news
commentary coming up
politicians often talk about reaching
across the aisle
jack kemp actually did it but he also
managed to help build the foundation
for the reagan revolution it's time to
renew the american
promise and to recapture the american
dream
and to give our nation a new birth of
freedom with liberty
equality and justice for all that's what
it means to be a republican
the former nfl star turned congressman
who died in 2009
was an economic adviser to three
presidents housing secretary under
president george
h.w bush and in 1996 became bob dole's
running mate
pitching not only equality in that
convention speech
but a fairer flatter tax code he also
didn't take politics personally and some
conservative thinkers inspired by him
are now advisors to president trump so
could kemp's way
be the path to a republican revival or
at least a boost for the trump campaign
first of all he was a charismatic figure
with a radiant
outgoing personality fox news senior
political analyst brett hume is the host
of a new fox nation documentary the jack
kemp playbook
he's a man who of such obvious goodwill
that people
of whatever political persuasions i
think liked him
and found him easy to be with and easy
to get along with
and he was and he was very interested in
economics
and made a kind of study of it at one
point in his life and he ended up being
one of the one of the most ardent
proponents
of cutting income tax uh income taxes
to boost the economy it was an idea that
was eventually uh
adopted by ronald reagan uh who passed a
bill which was along the lines of what
jack kemp had been talking about in fact
it was
it was often called the kemp roth tax
cut he was named for kemp
and a senator named bill ross from
delaware
the reason why i had bill ross anymore
is it needed a senate co-sponsor and he
agreed to do it but this was jack kemp's
baby all the way along and and and that
tax policy
has been a part of the republican
platform and playbook ever since
what else was in his playbook and and
could it help for the president to
follow well he was very much he was very
he was he was very much uh an advocate
of civil rights
and in his and and you can trace that
to his foot football career in which he
became a devoted friend of a number of
black athletes that he played with
in professional football and he was one
of their
he became one of their advocates and was
very much that way all along and of
course
it related to his view about the effect
of taxation because he believed that
the inner city neighborhoods could
benefit
from tax policies that attracted
businesses to those areas
so he was those were two issues that
were very important to him he was
he was otherwise a relatively
conventional republican
but on taxes and on civil rights he
stood out
i know that he was also a proponent of
getting government
out of the way when people needed help
well yeah
well he was all yeah well he was he was
jack kemp was
was interested in in deregulation as
well
um which has gone hand in hand with with
with the tax policy uh for many years
now and of course you look at donald
trump's agenda when he came in what did
he want to do
he wanted in order to lower the income
tax rates and he wanted to cut back on
the regulations
and it's a pretty good argument as to
which of those two policies
had the greater effect on the economy i
happen to believe that
the deregulatory policies were were very
very
important and maybe more important than
the tax policies and kemp was always an
advocate for that he was trying to clear
the way
for enterprise areas and enterprise
zones and he wanted
businesses to to flourish and to hire
and to do all the things that have so
benefited people through the years
right now though it seems like a real
tricky argument
to to be a fiscal conservative
especially when congress has already
spent so much
on pandemic related it wasn't help
kemp wasn't particularly a fiscal
conservative in fact he was an opponent
of what
um what some people at the time called
green eye shade economics in other words
he was not
his greatest goal was not to reduce the
federal deficit
his his greater goal was to grow the
economy and
he was and and if uh it was required to
borrow money to
to do certain things he was for that you
know
all other things being equal he would
have been happy to see spending lowered
but there was not a big priority with
him ever
do you think that right now for the
president and other republicans
running for reelection it's it is
complicated though because
you know obviously the senate gop bill
is about a third as big as what the
house
most recently passed for coronavirus
relief um but it's
it's still a true you know a trillion
dollars even if that bill were to pass
the levels of debt that we're
accumulating now are so staggering
that it's impossible to believe that
there won't be a a very severe day of
reckoning when all of this
is is has to you know have bills have to
be paid
and the worrisome thing is that the easy
way out of debt
for a government is to inflate to
inflate the currency
which makes the the debt that's owed
worth less
and my fear as you know as somebody
who's
observed this through the years is that
that's what will end up happening
but i can't trace my my thoughts about
that and jack kemp ever said that wasn't
his
preoccupation i know you've interviewed
former new york times journalist alex
berenson on the rundown
an outspoken critic of some of the
public policy decisions and also media
coverage
during the pandemic how do you think we
are handling
this crisis as a country
i think we've struggled because i think
we made a terrible mistake i think
the shutdowns in which we engage in
which we're now in some places engaging
again
are the worst public policy decision of
my lifetime
we've known from the start some things
about this disease we knew that it was
extremely dangerous
to elderly people and especially elderly
elderly people with certain pre-existing
health conditions
and then the death rates from the death
rates from this disease of people in
that age group
you know 70s and 80s in particular bear
that out
we've also known that children are
largely invulnerable to this disease
that very few of them catch it and
there's very little evidence that they
spread it very effectively
and when we've shut down the schools
nonetheless
presumably i think ultimately for the
benefit of the teachers who may be
worried about this but the evidence that
that that
kids spread it to teachers in any major
way is pretty lacking as well
so that in my opinion was a terrible
mistake and shutting down business is
the way we did
um has deprived people of work it is
deprived families
of and of course with the schools closed
families didn't have daycare people
couldn't work
even those that might have jobs some of
the millions of jobs lost
started to return as states started to
reopen
but it's too soon to know how many jobs
aren't coming back
just how many businesses have failed but
there are many
and the recent surge in coronavirus
cases has led to a rollback of
reopenings
threatening some businesses that did
survive the first round
hume says there are severe costs that
can't fully be calculated yet
the danger to children's health the
danger to mental health that people have
been cooped up for long periods of time
the danger to families who have been
cooped up
but all those things are real and they
were not part of the argument
when the decision was made these
decisions were made they were all about
one thing and that was
beating this disease but that wasn't the
only issue that faced the country
because beating the disease has its
own uh ancillary costs collateral damage
and the collateral damage from this has
been very severe indeed
and you know i don't i don't really
blame dr
fauci and burke's although they've made
some mistakes and some of them were
quite
real and serious because their only job
is to fight the disease
but for the government as a whole we
needed a much broader perspective on
on this whole matter we had we didn't
have it and i'm not sure we have it yet
do you think that president trump
not just for this but overall has a
playbook or is he really just winging it
well he has a playbook to some extent
remember he promised to do a number of
things
in his campaign in 2016 and he's tried
hard to keep those promises
he hasn't always succeeded presidents
don't always succeed at all in keeping
all their campaign promises
but that has constituted kind of a
playbook what he doesn't have right now
is a fresh new set of uh proposals
to constitute a re-election agenda um he
talks about certain things and
he talks about infrastructure measure
and so on which he talked about
has talked about for a long time but but
he hasn't really sketched out
uh a new platform for his presidency if
he gets a second term
and as a political matter it would be
very helpful
for him to do that well one more thing
and
you've covered a lot of elections um any
idea where
this one is going or if maybe taking a
page out of the jack kemp playbook would
help the president at this point
well taking a a page out of jack kemp's
playbook in terms of his
outward attitudes toward people would
would certainly help although it may be
too late
uh for that for donald trump because
people have figured out what they think
of him
um but remember this about donald trump
uh he's behind i don't think there's any
doubt he's behind he was behind
four years ago at about this stage as
well
um he's he's behind nationally he's
behind in most of the battleground
states
and you can tell he knows that and
believes that by the mere fact that he's
he's the one that wants more debates
candidates who are leading in
presidential elections want fewer
debates
that's just how it works because you you
know you don't want to take the chance
that something could happen in the
debate that would change the course of
the election
i'll be surprised if they get three
debates that would amaze me
but you know trump trump has some time
but he needs an agenda and he needs to
discipline himself against doing the
things
that that people find obnoxious he did
that in the closing weeks of the 2016
campaign
for the final six weeks or so i'd say he
basically stopped with the tweeting
he went to all the states that he needed
to go to and he got on the messages
that uh his polling and and you know
what his advisors were telling him
and what he i think he as well sensed he
needed to talk about
and and he ran away with the election
and won it
came from behind and won the election
well he's behind again
he's got a lot of work to do fox news
senior political analyst britt hume
thanks very much sir for your time
you bet lisa thank you very much for
having me on
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
read and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
lorenzo liberty is on a mission he's a
high school sophomore from florida who
makes hand
carved wooden u.s flags it all started
last january when i went to go feed the
homeless with my church and my family
i met a homeless veteran and it kind of
stuck with me from there
he's putting his art out there in a big
way as he told fox news
my goal is to get right now a flag in a
hospital in every single state to
support our new heroes
he's got a special connection to one of
those front line workers too
his mom who's a physician's assistant i
do it to support our heroes in general
the ones that are forgotten and everyone
who risks their lives
day in and day out to make a better usa
the flags come in different sizes
including three feet long with the
biggest being seven feet long
one has a thin blue line to honor law
enforcement while another has a red line
for firefighters
he says a three foot flag takes about 15
to 20 hours to make
dedication wake up early go to bed late
so it's a lot of
carving torching staining and drilling
as for after high school he says he's
already thought about that
possibly join the military and yeah
coast guard probably you can see the
flags and learn more at lorenzo's
website
heroicflags.com tanya j powers
fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
greg jarrett
what's on your mind sally yates who
served as deputy attorney general during
a critical period as the russia
collusion hoax evolved
trashed fired fbi director james comey
during new testimony wednesday before
the senate judiciary committee
she readily agreed that comey went rogue
in his
unauthorized pursuit of former national
security adviser michael flynn
but of course that was stating the
obvious it was
all too easy comey managed to turn
himself
into a human pinata when he engaged in
blatant
acts of corruption but like comey yates
was a model of prevarication on all else
she minimized her own negligence and
incompetence
while blaming everybody else some of her
testimony was factually wrong
demonstrably so instead of owning up to
her own mistakes or
malevolence yates doubled down she
smeared people associated
with the 2016 trump presidential
campaign
unbelievably she accused george
papadopoulos
of being connected to russian
intelligence
there is no evidence of that there never
was any
in a moment of uncommon candor yates
said she regrets that the fisa court was
deceived defrauded would be more
accurate
by the warrant application she signed
twice
to spy on trump campaign associate
carter page
yet she didn't have the courage to
apologize to page
for violating his constitutional rights
and ruining his life the spine on page
was based almost entirely on the
anti-trump dossier
declassified documents recently made
public show
the fbi debunked the dossier a mere
four days after trump was inaugurated
if yates had done her job
conscientiously she would have known
this
and tossed the dossier in the nearest
garbage can
but on wednesday yates still refused to
admit that the dossier was
junk she did admit that all the errors
and omissions identified by the
inspector general were unacceptable yet
yates was the one who accepted them
without question
so much for diligence or responsible
leadership
the most laughable canard peddled by
aids came as
she refused to admit any bias on the
part of fbi agents
really how about the agent who
fraudulently altered an fbi document
to hide exculpatory evidence while
incriminating
carter page in one of the warrant
applications that
yates signed what about all the
profanity-laced
tirades exchanged by peter strzok and
his lover lisa page
directed at the very man they were
investigating
donald trump no bias there claimed sally
yates yates trashed comey for going
rogue but the record is clear it was
yates
who went rogue as well both are equally
unprincipled
and unscrupulous their mutual goal was
to
wreak havoc on the incoming president
and generate a
public scandal that would damage donald
trump
sadly for the nation and the institution
of the presidency
they managed to accomplish it i'm greg
jarrett
fox news legal analyst be sure to pick
up my latest book
witch hunt the story of the greatest
mass delusion
in american political history
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with bret bear with updates
from reporters on the trail
and in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race
go to foxnewspodcast.com and download
the campaign with brett bear now
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes